joining us tonight Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell mr. leader thanks
for being here the past few minutes
Bernie Sanders put out a statement
saying that a president Bernie Sanders
would get Medicare for all through he's
pushing for filibuster reform says it
would get 51 votes Democratic senators
quote need to be prepared to do what
polls show that rank-and-file democrats
want and that is a medicare for all
single-payer system your reaction your
reaction that not as long as i'm
majority leader it ought to be called
medicare for none because as the setup
piece pointed out 180 million americans
would lose the private health insurance
they many of them have negotiated for at
work medicare itself that current
recipients have been paying into all
these years would be completely drained
by adding all these additional people if
you want to turn america into a
socialist country this is the first step
that coupled of course with a green new
deal which would eliminate a whole lot
of jobs i think what we've seen here is
full socialism on display and the
democratic primaries for president and
even those who are skeptical about it
like senator klobuchar are are saying a
public option well that's not much
different because if you have a public
option i guarantee you the public option
will also drive all the private
insurance companies out of business so
look this is this is a prescription for
turning America into a Western European
country where's the GOP plan on health
care well what we but we want to make
sure everybody knows is that we're all
in favor of covering pre-existing
conditions and that's really not
endangered by the current litigation
that's working its way through the
courts I'm all in favor of working on
what should be called niche fixes to try
to improve the current system obviously
Obama care has entirely too high
co-payments and deductibles we ought to
be working on something like that there
is a bipartisan effort underway in the
Senate to try to get down the cost of
prescription drugs those are the kinds
of things that could actually pass but I
guarantee you next year what's going to
be on display across this country is a
debate about whether we want to
America into a socialist country I never
thought by the way that we'd be debating
the virtues of capitalism in America in
my lifetime you backed off last week
taking another run at trying to replete
repeal and replace Obamacare did the
president get too far over his skis
there well look we made that effort last
Congress it didn't work clearly the
Democratic House is not going to pass it
so we're not going to spend time in the
Senate on things that have you know
literally no chance of becoming law what
happens if the Supreme Court rules
Obamacare on Constitution then we'll
have to revisit the whole matter and but
that's not it that's not likely to
happen any time for the next couple of
years so I think people ought to just
take a deep breath and settle down and
let us work on some of these more modest
fixes that I think the American people
need and deserve you know that's not how
the president talks about it he says get
rid of Obamacare after the election now
well after after he and I had this
discussion he indicated he would come up
with a plan and he'd run on it during
the campaign and if the Republicans were
able to regain the house and hold the
Senate that would be a time for us to be
voting on it I want to ask you just
since senator Sanders talked about
filibuster and filibuster reform you've
executed this maneuver to speed up the
confirmation of many of the president's
nominees you're on the record saying
there isn't an appetite to get rid of
the legislative filibuster but didn't
that move kind of cracked the door a
little bit more suggesting that maybe
that is going to gain some some strength
with lawmakers that the filibuster is
not going to be around for long
look this is a little bit down in the
weeds for your viewers Busbee they get
it but the Senate's n't got two
calendars the executive calendar and the
legislative coming we're in the
personnel business the house is not
personnel until Bush 43 was elected was
always handled in a fairly smooth way
with a simple majority legislation is
the essence of the Senate it's always
required a supermajority and it has to
good effects it either kills bad stuff
or it guarantees that both sides work
out a compromise that's the essence
of the Senate it's exactly what George
Washington hope is then it would become
the place where things were slowed down
the place where things were thought over
and the place where a lot of bad ideas
didn't become law so you're fighting
Democrats here on the filibuster and and
maybe the White House - right well the
president was antsy about this I told
him we weren't gonna do it and we didn't
and I think now he's probably thinking I
was right I want to get your thoughts on
the testimony today from the Attorney
General he got a lot of attention you
heard earlier he was asked if there was
spying on the Trump campaign he said yes
here's how some top Democrats reacted to
them public in conspiracy theory
nonsense it says show games look at this
imaginary conspiracy versus the fact
that the Russians interfered with our
elections I'm very concerned about the
statements made my attorney general bar
I think that they undermine our
Constitution they undermine the role of
the Attorney General
I don't trust Barr I trust more okay
what's your reaction to that well it's
obviously the question whether you trust
bill Barr not he was a confirmed
unanimously as Attorney General way back
in Bush 41 he's an honorable man he's
not over there trying to cover anything
up he's going to send us a Muller report
that is as open as possible and when I
say as possible
I'm pretty confident he's not going to
throw innocent people who weren't
charged under the bus and ruin their
reputation or reveal classified
information if you send that up to the
hill I guarantee you it'll get out well
what about the part about the early part
of the investigation are you confident
bar and or a Senate committee is going
to get to the bottom I'm pretty sure
there was already an inspector general
in the Justice Department looking at
that particular problem that was related
to the deputy in the FBI who was
dismissed it's worth a look and I think
the Inspector General in the Justice
Department is already looking at that
and I think the Attorney General's
within it right to do that the president
said today it was an attempted coup
illegal takedown of a president and
treason agree with them look I I think
it's a molar report is something the
president ought to be happy about he
basically said what the president was
hoping to hear and I think once it's
revealed as much of it as we can legally
be revealed the president should be
applauding it Senate Watchers there are
a lot of them say your agenda in the
Senate is pretty limited restricted
mostly to confirming nominees not robust
fair that's partially true because the
Democratic House is not likely to take
up our best ideas and we're not likely
to take up theirs on the other hand
personnel is important to Supreme Court
justices 30 Circuit Court judges the
most in the first two years of any
administration in history we've done
seven more circuits now that's 37 we
have 53 district judges backed up these
are lifetime appointments they're going
to make a huge impact on the country in
the future now that we've modified the
rules in a way that will allow us to
expedite these appointments we're going
to do all of the district judges
that's not unimportant that's going to
have the longest impact on the country
of anything we do legislatively one of
the few things you've had major votes on
and you mentioned it is to criticize
Democrats you got a vote on the green
new deal just to put Democratic really
presidential hopefuls in the Senate on
the record you decried which called show
votes during the government shutdown how
was that not a show vote well it was but
you know I don't intend to spend all of
our time doing that sort of thing but
once in a while people ought to go on
record and decide whether they're
willing to vote for what they say
they're for I mean when we had the green
New Deal vote in the Senate only four
Democrats voted against it the rest of
them voted president including people
who co-sponsored it I think we should
assume that all the rest of them are
actually in favor of this job-killing
proposal do you think Congress should do
anything to fight climate change yeah I
believe that climate change is certainly
happening I think it ought to be
addressed about technology and not by
having the government shut down our
me and caused us to lose an incredible
number of jobs
speaking about shutdowns will there be
another shutdown in the fall no why
because it's not a sensible thing to do
and I don't believe we'll do that again
we do need by the way in order to avoid
that I was smoking with both the speaker
and the president within the last few
days we have convened a discussion at
the staff level to see if we can agree
on how much to spend this year and next
year to avoid just that kind of thing
the Democrats pulled out their pulled
off their budget vote the other day
what's your relationship with Nancy
Pelosi can you characterize it well I
like Nancy I mean we've known each other
for years so there's no personal
animosity we have very different views
but the American people have given us
divided government and in order to for
the government to function we have to be
able to discuss these things with each
other and we're going to do that with
the administration on this issue of how
much we're going to spend this year and
next year is there anything we're
heading into this election season we're
always one election away from solving
big things it seems is there any chance
of bipartisan deals on drug prices
possibly infrastructure if we can deal
with how to pay for it we've been to all
been talking about infrastructure
including the president for a couple of
years now if you want to do a really
significant large infrastructure bill we
need to have a lot of straight talk from
everybody on both sides about how you're
gonna pay for it
aggression we desperately need some
immigration legislation the president's
entirely correct about the crisis of the
border and the fact that our immigration
laws do not allow us to deal with the
crisis at the border I would hope that
finally after years of gridlock on this
and by the way it's important to point
out that in 2009 and 2010 with the
Democrats control the entire government
they never brought up immigration reform
never when they owned it it's finally
time for us to step up and not only
solve the crisis at the border but do
some changes in the immigration laws
that are sensible that's stealing this
summer yes we have to do that and will
will tackle that at some point
which Democratic presidential candidate
do you fear the most you know I'm not
gonna answer that question I'll tell you
this I think any the Democrat who
ultimately wins the nomination is
probably going to say oh of course I'm a
capitalist but I think what we need to
look at is what they're advocating not
what they call themselves and any
Democrat who's sympathetic to packing
the Supreme Court getting rid of the
electoral college the green New Deal
medicare-for-all is in my view taking
America in the direction of socialism
and do you think you'll be pushing
another Supreme Court nominee through
who knows if there's a vacancy we will
all right senator thanks very much thank
you